wife do you want to be
I feel like um I was born quite maternal
quite wisely and I
sometimes it's a con because you carry
worthy duties before when you did
girlfriend prices when I am a wife
um I have kind of similar views I'll you
know I want to raise my children to a
certain age and then they can get into
education or whatever
um if during that time my man is the
provider then I'll have to step up and
do most homely things but then when I do
continue to go back to work or start
providing also whether it's for everyone
or just you know partly
um I'd want him to step in slightly more
and maybe one night help with the
cooking or unload the dishwasher I don't
think it should be all on me
um
but yeah I'm a very given person I'm
very caring nurturing person so whatever
he needs if you need help within his
work or you know I'll always try I won't
I won't ever say no or decline anything
I always try I